wheelchairs is coming to chess.com
enchant your pieces with one of two
spells jump or freeze players start with
two jump spells and five free spells
which we charge after five moves you may
cast your spare whenever you wish before
making a regular chest move jump is a
spell cast to one square wherein if
there is a piece on that square other
pieces can jump over the Charmed piece
the freeze spell is cast over a three by
three square area and the pieces in this
area are temporarily Frozen in place
to defeat your opponent
come see what supercell and chess.com
have cooked up in our new variant spell
chess dropping on September 1st